I was with the homies chillin and I
don't know
what's up everybody should boil and
fresh and welcome to finish to lyric
where we pair athletes with some of
their favorite artists today's guests my
gods yg and Todd Gurley
we're gonna test Todd on his knowledge
of YG's music slammed up when I woke up
in the Polo riding the low-cut oh then
we're gonna even the playing field and
we're gonna go to some classic song some
popular songs and we're gonna test both
you guys and then we're gonna chop it up
and then we're gonna get to know you
guys better and it failed generating the
same or more then a player should be
getting the same or know what I'm saying
that's just me being one honey
finally we're gonna shoot a music video
where you're gonna switch roles and
you're gonna be the star and you're
gonna be the height man you ready yeah
let's get it
[Music]
fellas fellas Todd can you hear me yeah
so now it's time to test your knowledge
or YG's music the first song it's big
and back being boo these guys don't play
that wife you like sick I don't play
that I'm a real bumping with her mother
attitude walk up in the spot you would
think I'm mad at you I was with the
homies chillin don't stop me don't stop
me always taught me over start me over
so now it's time to chop it up you know
I'm gonna pull a car from the deck I'm
gonna read it and then when I go around
we're gonna answer this question ready
the first question the time what do you
remember the first time about the first
time you start listening to whitey and
was in high school I left eleventh grade
and just always kind of listened food
and my homeboys was just like and we
decide to start calling you TG for honey
and that's when I made I made my
histogram that's what all my teammates
just start calling College High School
and if they're the top to the to the
next question you could get that one
side yeah why'd you what about Todd
Gurley has made you a big fan
the first thing first it was like some
years ago I was on tour like highlight
2013-14 and one of the old boys he came
to the show and he seen one of my
peoples and was like I gotta get I gotta
go talk to yg you see me at home eat our
girly why don't you send me he what I'm
heavy
he said that's when I hopped on the
phone with Brooke back in the day he
said I'm like yeah we was just chopping
it up was on my good lucky you know
and even sit around just [ __ ] we're
asking I'll and I'm like oh this is
crazy
how about this it's crazy but that's
number one
you feel me I support people that
support me or date to the fullest
they didn't broke nice though like so
it's like he nice regardless and we
neighbors is this crazy broke boob man
it's love you know I'm saying bro Savage
I'm inspired by football I go to the
games and being inspired to go do what I
do after that with all my fiendish stuff
and the music and [ __ ] like that Tosh
how you want me to start over yes time
you're high
I'm gonna give you one more chance
welcome to the spot you would think the
matter - I was with the homies chilling
down with Commission and they came back
shoes my homies came back shoot ain't
nobody hitting none so this getting
stupid I was with the homies chillin I
tried Riverdance see bigger back then
bolt verse to the Sun coming up you know
when the Sun come up them guns come out
Click Clack pow pow pow pow pow pow
Rob and then they're trying to rob my
stop hey you sent your home into jail
you were she sent you a snitch uh hey yg
so how do you doing that one oh man he
got like 25%
how do you feel about players in the
field Miller I mean you've been you've
been a part of that you're gonna part
out I mean uh are I'm gonna keep real
once again I was talking to cabinet
about this um like when they start
milling at the time it was a lot of
black people was getting killed by the
police it was just a lot of crazy one
it's still four but it was just crazy at
the time when they was kneeling just
what the nil was about naming people I
don't know if it was in a fail or just
the people in the world you can they
were trying to make it about the
military and not listening start bro we
ain't talked about that military off
from the streets but I respect the
mother to I respect everybody to go to
the military is willing to sacrifice
their life for the country they from
just to see how they tried to turn it in
is his craziest like but we talk about
something else
oh definitely a whole different light
bar people getting killed but you were a
part of that that whole you know them
taking his name off of your song and he
like was like how did you feel about
that I didn't know nothing about it I
didn't agree to it I didn't know nothing
so I just feel like he was right it was
shaking this community situation with
somebody I'm cool with and support been
supported from before he had this going
on it just made us a little crazy cuz
when I found out about it they have I
woke up you think they hit me like hey
buddy building took away my circle bad I
like what fight it no no I got a duty no
sir so just put me in a weird situation
but when I talked to him he like brought
no you
my chauffeur though we gonna figure it
out alright y'all the next song twists
my fingers yg you're gonna start it off
and Todd's gonna finish the lyric we'll
do it my damn the cup my pants and puts
my pain with my hand I'm about to pull
of sugar I didn't press the issue won't
strike the group blood neither checkbook
we won't your ways I went to sleep
climbed up when I woke up in the Polo
Rock the low-cut we are giving another
chance
and we're gonna start with yg first down
with that [ __ ] I'm out to put a Suge
Knight and press the issue on site
real blood leave a check we don't go
fast and what the City Frank done but I
woke up in my polo I rocking a low-cut
one my son's like I could've got it but
when it got low low its copping off you
rep because there's a no-no I can hop
out solo suck as a folk folk I probably
need three mo the deep emo they see my
attitude I have a attitude that I my
side of that which mad at me folks when
you see NBA players receive guaranteed
contracts how did I make you feel oh how
do I make me feel it made me feel good
man I just seeing another player first
of all anybody on Kenny especially you
know a black player you know get that
played at payday we always in the same
shoes so y'all my eyes how old would he
be out of there man
oh I mean what I've been hearing like
the inner cell makes more money than a
bee
so if the NFL generating the same over
more then they players should be getting
the same for more info I'm saying that's
just me being a honey
so this is the yg so you've been on the
record saying that the NBA is off do you
think that LeBron James could play for
the Los Angeles Rams he said the law
says was right yeah well you said I said
then he was so yeah well say this like
last year
boys flopping here maybe maybe was
around floppy oh no bro I'll remember
that book LeBron look like he'd be a
tight into some after receivers here
like he likes son like how tall his bro
would you take him on the team oh yeah
right there receiver tighter and they
all all the time in the region and the
NBA is a lot of guys are flopping to
clean about fouls where's a football
like you get hit you're getting soft too
and I forget soft with all those rules
I felt like he's getting soft at the
same time I understand why because of
the shitty football players someone
would be going through it like later on
and they like me I'm saying and it's
like that [ __ ] real you still got to be
a tough mom will be on the field playing
football because it's just consistent
contact Sam like our air shake going up
with you sticking with the Ray Lewis you
know a fan Patrick Willis Troy Polamalu
everyday everybody getting their hair
smacked off I'm obviously you know you
want to protect the players but just
well that's what we saying growing up
we know we know how to play flag
football
all right now this time we're gonna put
both of you guys on the hot seat
rick ross hustling let's go everyday I'm
hustling everyday I'm hustling everyday
I'm hustling everyday I'm hustling you
talking with I'm the boss
7:45 right on right as we grow I cut him
I cut him large I cut him fat I'm
keeping them coming back I keep them
coming back the distribution that landed
I got distribution flying across the
Atlantic
I know Pablo Noriega he told me a
hundred favors I job who we think one
now who won that one
we 50/50 yeah yeah yeah that first verse
the tears know that we're everybody yeah
any uh any questions you guys have each
other Joy's want to ask for oh I got a
question
help God although I know like we got as
a team
first period when y'all get like month
another month there's a rapper family so
very successful when they pull up to the
games and they doing whatever they doing
and you can baby on a support ship how
y'all feel about that you can y'all buy
auto-ship fake it like my way which all
the wood we just like we just be joking
all the time everybody like you know why
she had to gain you know we on the lease
on the sidelines like damn you like we
want we always say that so we always go
talk ah stuff but you know we appreciate
everybody I do come to the game
so we didn't finish the lyric we chopped
it up and now it's time you ready yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the new ass work cuz the white folks
don't know hey you killed how you
feeling I'm good I'm good how do I live
yeah thank for watching this new boy
Lance pressed finish the lyric yg Todd
Gurley we are out
[Music]